- Hi, hi you guys.
- Hi Meegan.
- Wait we haven't been
introduced, who is this?
- Hi I'm Meegan.
- [Heben] Oh my god Meegan's here!
- Nice to meet you guys.
- [Heben] Oh my god!
(groovy music)
- We're so excited to be
here with Jordan Peele.
- Excited to be here.
- [Heben] Aye.
- Yes yes yes yes.
- Directorial debut for Get Out.
We watched it.
- Go see the movie it is
insane.
- We were terrified.
- Yes.
- [Heben] (singing) We were terrified!
- We're gonna do something
fun called Pew Pew Pew.
- [All] Pew Pew Pew.
- I'm excited for Pew Pew Pew.
- Yes, um this is our rapid fire seg-
(bleeping)
- This is our rapid question fire segment.
- That's alright, the words
don't have to be in order.
- They don't.
- You just gotta get 'em out.
You just gotta get 'em out.
What does your childhood smell like?
- Hm. Uh Skittles and rain.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- That's really cute. (laughing) Sorry.
- Yeah, I guess like-
- That was really beautiful.
- Yeah hey, you know, that's
two of my favorite things.
- OK, OK.
- Was there a moment you ever
rebelled with your white mom?
You're like, white mom, you don't get me!
(laughing)
- Did you call her white mom as well?
- White mom!
- White mother!
- Where's black mom? I know
she's out there somewhere.
(laughing)
- White mother. You do not understand.
- No, you know I didn't
have any sort of like
racial rebellion in any way.
You know I had the normal
high school like angst thing
for a bit but I was you
know, a mamma's boy.
I'm pretty much uh,
and you know she did a real good job.
- So let's do some Would You Rather's.
Would you rather vote
for the presidency of the United States
Rachel Dolezal,
- Ooh.
- Or Omarosa?
- Rachel Dolezal in a second.
- What?
Wait why? Talk to me.
You thought about that
in like two seconds.
- I think um, Rachel Dolezal
has spent her life
trying to do good things.
She's been working for black people.
It's confusing, right?
Because she wants to be black.
- (laughs) Why?
- And everybody think, what you doin'?
- That's not what you want,
that's not what you want.
- I think her big mistake,
like she could've gotten
away with just being like,
yeah I like my hair like this, I like it.
She just didn't have to say
my parents are black though.
(laughs)
- Yeah. She did outright lie.
- She went for it.
- So one of my Would You
Rather's was based on
partly in truth.
So you're a woman in this situation.
- Hey girl.
- (laughs) Hey girl!
- Hi, hi you guys.
- Hi Meegan.
- Wait we haven't been
introduced, who is this?
- Hi I'm Meegan.
- [Heben] Oh my god Meegan's here!
- Nice to meet you guys.
- [Heben] Oh my god!
(laughs)
- Would you rather go on a date with a man
who has a pickup truck but no need for it,
(laughs)
or a man who has five cats?
- Um, I would say that
(laughing)
I've met a man with a pickup truck
with five cats in the back.
(laughs)
- No.
- And let me tell you, ladies,
(laughing)
he was good.
- Oh, really?
- He was good.
- So do you think that it's something
about the pickup truck?
- You just, you want a guy who knows
how to haul that (bleeping) off.
So do you approve?
- I can't believe I
didn't see that coming.
- That was excellent.
I feel like I set it up
it was a layup.
- You set it up.
- It was a layup and
then I was just like yes.
- I saw nothing.
(groovy music)